dan is with us to start off this hour in
Kansas City hi Dan how are you good
I was wanting to call in today I've had
a question between saving or spending
debt down where I fortunately paid off
my outstanding credit cards and small
interest loans and so I just had my
first and second mortgage and I'm trying
to trying to pay the second mortgage off
as quick as possible but I know in a
year I've got a lot of expenses for home
repairs and potentially replacing wife's
car I'm trying to figure out I'm trying
to save about five hundred a month and
I'm paying about 600 a month to pay to
the second mortgage down I'm wondering
if I should be more aggressive something
in the that down or more aggressive with
the saving what is the balance on your
second mortgage at 17,000 and what's
your household income the gross is about
a hundred and fifty thousand a year okay
when we have a second mortgage that is
less than half your annual income which
yours is we count it in baby step two we
call it which is where we have everyone
pay off all your debts except your home
now if you had an $80,000 second
mortgage we wouldn't do that we would
leave it at what we call baby step six
and you just pay on it only as you've
got ready to pay on your home but this
is this is like a credit card debt or a
car payment it's a small debt and so
what I would do is I would stop all
investing and I would stop all saving of
any kind and I would pay this off in an
instant do you have any money saved or
invested that is not in a retirement
account at this point no I've tried to
save up for emergency and know much
about about $3,000 all right then we
take that baby step one when we teach
people is a process called the baby
steps - the fastest path to building
wealth okay and baby step 1 is $1,000
saved as a starter beginner emergency
fund anything above the
we throw it at debt and we stop all
investing and saving and baby step two
and that's become debt-free everything
but your home and that would include a
small home equity loan link you have so
that's where you are you're at that step
so I'm taking $2,000 I'm thrown out of
your three I'm throwing it at this the
car and the home repairs are on hold for
right now they're they're a thing you
need to do but they're not an emergency
today and you need to clear this debt as
quickly as possible once that's gone
then it should be gone in no time I mean
if you stop everything and completely
point all of your guns at this one debt
that's only $15,000 after this
discussion and you make a hundred and
fifty you should be done with it in just
a matter of months right a couple months
just knock it out fast
well I yeah I still looking at about
$1,200 a month
so it could still take nine this
shouldn't - no you make $150,000 a year
it shouldn't okay I and I don't know how
that is with taxes and insurance but
when I calculated what we actually bring
home I think it's closer to 90 - you
don't pay $60,000 a year in taxes did
you but I I I looked at what might take
home was understand did you get a huge
tax refund no actually how much is going
into 401 K right now I'm putting 6% in
stop that that's what I'm saying
stop all investing temporarily and
completely focus because your take-home
pay I'm talking about after taxes your
actual tax bill on a hundred and fifty
thousand I mean you should be bringing
home 120 your tax bills about 30 and so
about $10,000 a month - your health
insurance and your how I don't know how
expensive your health insurance is but
120 - health insurance and then just
crunch your budget down to nothing and
when you start doing that $15,000 goes
away in a matter of about three months
for months you should be done with this
before Christmas for sure and then I
want you to build your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses raise
that thousand dollars up to about twenty
thousand bucks and then pay cash for a
car and then pay cash for the home
repairs and only then do you restart
your 401k and that's baby step four and
you put fifteen percent of your income
not six percent into your 401k see
what's happening right now Dan is you're
falling into the classic trap that
causes people to not get traction is
you're trying to do six things at once
and none of them are getting done you
feel that you're putting money in your
401k you're trying to pay extra on this
on this loan and you're trying to save
money for a car and none of them are
really going very fast and you make a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year and you got no traction so the
difference is what I tell people to do
is what you focus on is what wins and
that's caused people to be able to win
that you can do whatever you want to do
down but you caught me and this is our
plan and it is worked for millions of
people so it's what we tell folks to do
well hang on I'm gonna send you a copy
of the book the Total Money Makeover as
my gift read through that and then make
your decision
it's very persuasive because it's
correct but you know the the things that
we focus on are the things we win at and
when you try to do six things at once
nothing you know it's a jack of all
trades master of none
nothing gets done nothing gets done when
you try to do six things at once there's
no power focus and so it makes you very
nervous to not have but a thousand
dollars saved it makes you very nervous
to turn off your 401k but it ought to
make you very nervous that you don't
have but $3,000 to your name and you
make 150 grand that ought to make you
nervous and that ought to tell you that
you're not getting the traction that you
should be getting here if you do what
I'm talking about in one year your life
will be dramatically changed in the
financial area dramatically because you
make really good money
you're just not winning with it so hope
that's helpful to you